what's going on guys this is rob and we
are picking back up again with uh
devil's reign i know you guys have been
asking for it but i i cannot make the
comics come out faster as much as i wish
i could i cannot control when comics get
released so uh this story i do love i
absolutely love it this issue is just as
awesome as the first one that's one of
the things about chip sadarsky man this
guy this guy's ridiculously talented
when it comes to writing writing comic
book stories crossover events more than
anything else but what this does is this
initially picks up basically with danny
rand right if you guys recall the last
video that we did that basically the
entirety of new york superhero community
has for the most part begun to go
underground right that the kingpin
essentially had legislation passed that
basically outlawed superheroes in the
city of new york and it's creating a
more i guess a smaller version of the
original civil war event but what this
has led to is kingpin enlisting villains
to basically play out the roles of
people who would essentially enforce
superheroes being rounded up and
basically being arrested for vigilante
activity right so it's kind of ironic
that kingpin would use what are in
effect people with powers to basically
round up people with powers but it's not
that dissimilar from what tony stark did
during civil war the tony stark had the
thunderbolts and then he also had the
mighty avengers right they basically
went around and rounded up people who
were violating superhuman registration
and so what you have here is of course
danny rand basically talking directly
with uh with luke cage the two of them
kind of having a conversation luke case
tell them look man like you know we're
basically going to go get with steve
rogers and we're all essentially going
to go underground avengers work out when
we're better together like everybody's
just kind of keeping everything safe and
danny rand's response is that he'll
basically just be fine right he's like i
might just drive north and lay low just
in case i mean he's got the money and
the resources to do it that while wilson
fisk is implementing this anti-superhero
legislation basically his authority is
not on the same level as tony starks was
during the events of civil war tony
stark could have frozen people's assets
if he chose to right that's the kind of
leeway and the sort of authority he had
that was given to him both as director
of shield and essentially as a
government liaison by the person who was
basically implementing all this and
making it happen fisk doesn't have that
kind of authority here and so it'd
really give danny rand as a ultra rich
guy the ability to just kind of take off
but before he can he's basically met by
the arrival of crossbones now the fight
between crossbones and danny rand this
is kind of a cool thing crossbones is
one of those little unsung guys in
marvel comics right he just doesn't
quite get enough respect and that was
compounded by the events of of the
marvel cinematic universe but crossbones
is pretty legit right this guy was
trained by taskmaster he's very very
capable now danny rand of course is a
master martial artist so he's able or at
least seemingly able to get his upper
hand on on crossbones and we don't
really see how it all concludes all we
really get here is that with everything
popping off because danny rand is like
30 blocks away there's no real way for
them to get there that tony stark and
luke cage and jessica jones can't really
access a quinn jet that tony stark's
armor is locked down as soon as the
forces of wilson fisk tried to enter
into his home so they don't really have
access to anything that could get them
to danny ran i mean they could try right
but to travel 30 blocks in new york
anyone who's been to that city will tell
you it's gonna take more than a car
[Music]
right you're literally gonna have to fly
there and so as a result of that they're
like okay if we're going to help this
city and we're going to fix this we
can't deviate and try to go get danny
rand we basically got to leave him right
the needs of the mini outweigh the needs
of the few the guy's a master martial
artist i'm sure he'll be okay and so at
that point you switch over to wilson
fisk when he's confronted by the new
daredevil elektra now here's the thing
and i'm a little i'm a little ashamed to
say this i have not been reading
daredevil i have no idea what's going on
here
[Laughter]
i don't know why elektra is daredevil
right now i mean i have a general idea
right just from what people have been
tweeting and talking about but i don't
really i don't know the ins and outs of
this so i am ashamed to say that as a
comic book youtuber
i am being negligent in my duties here's
my question for you guys should i be
reading daredevil right now right like
is there a double comic a comic that i
should be reading at the moment because
i'm not gonna lie i think the idea of
elektra basically replacing daredevil is
kind of cool and i'd be interested in
seeing how that whole thing's unfold so
those of you guys who are reading
daredevil should i be reading it
is it a resounding yes is it is it an
absolute no do not read it it's awful
let me know what you guys think the
important thing here though we don't
really know the ins and outs of what's
going on here the important thing is
that given the history of elektra it's
basically being an assassin that when
she shows up here at the office at the
office of kingpin right off the bat he
was like okay so i was kind of expecting
this somewhere along the line right like
i know you're the new daredevil i know
your history i know what you're about i
know that most likely somewhere along
the line you would come here to try to
kill me here's the thing that's not
going to happen right like i get that
this whole thing with you guys right you
guys are superheroes and all kind of
stuff but do you really believe that
because you have these freakish lives
that resulted in you getting freakish
powers you can just somehow do whatever
it is that you want to do not a chance
right and as soon as she pulls a weapon
on him that's when he realizes yeah like
you're you're here to kill me he's like
but here's the thing you've neutered
yourself right like you're playing the
long game with the real daredevil you
don't kill like you used to so why are
you here right if you have come here
with the intention of somehow
intimidating me and getting me to stand
down because i'm so terrified of the
dreaded electronagios
one of the deadliest assassins in the
world then let me help you understand
your your place in the bigger picture
right he's like there is someone who
came here before you did and they want
to meet you right they want to fight you
and they want you to meet them at a
particular location go go do your thing
right there's nothing for you here
you're not going to kill me and in a
hand-to-hand fight i would tear you
apart so nothing's going to happen
nothing's going to come of this right go
and face off against that guy who wanted
to fight you because here there's really
nothing going on now the reality and
really the reason why she leaves in the
first place is seemingly because of the
fact that kingpin basically seems to
know what she did how she betrayed matt
murdock and that if matt finds out
she'll lose everything again i don't
know the ins and outs of what's going on
here i feel like i should be reading
daredevil but i really really feel like
i should be reading this so i'm gonna do
that right i'm gonna go on comicology
and i'm gonna read daredevil so having
said that we switch over to avengers
mansion right now here's the thing
avengers mansion hasn't been used for a
long long time right at mama comics they
haven't used it for quite some time and
in fact the avengers mansion itself has
really turned into a place of tourism
right where people go when they visit
wow this is where the avengers used to
hang out and all that kind of stuff so
it's a very very attractive thing as far
as building up money for the city of new
york but the sub-basement of avengers
mansion that thing is still in operation
that it operates secretly and it's
really more of a bunker that's one of
the things that i kind of like about
what chipsadarski's doing here it's very
nick fury right those of you guys who
don't know anything about nick fury i
mean like old school nick fury right the
white guy nick fury not samuel jackson
that guy had bunkers everywhere he was
the most paranoid guy ever right and it
kind of makes sense right when you're
like the man on the wall and you've got
access to all this information and you
know more about what's going on in the
world and seemingly anybody else in the
world uh you start to realize just how
fast things could go sideways so nick
fury had bunkers on top of bunkers on
top of bunkers he had hideouts all over
the place right but one of the things
here is that having this place in in the
basement in the sub-basement of the
avengers mansion it's a place that
hasn't been accessed for quite some time
now one of the other things that goes on
here and this is a really really cool
concept and it's one of the reasons why
so many people were pissed off that the
luke cage tie-in for devil's reign was
canceled is that tony stark ends up
realizing there's a handful of kids who
are sitting outside the building and
they basically record the tony starks
here of course no one's supposed to know
that they're going to the sub-basement
of avengers mansion so tony stark
initially tries to bribe them and then
luke cage steps in and says look guys
like with everything going on here right
now even you have to realize that
superheroes being outlawed in the city
of new york that's a bad thing right
that villains are basically the law
enforcement now do you really trust that
they're somehow going to turn over a new
leaf and do good things and so he's like
look like the city is in serious danger
you guys are in serious danger do me a
solid right now here's the big
difference this is why luke cage was
always a great character here's the big
difference between luke cage danny rand
even spider-man and people like tony
stark and captain america and so on and
so forth tony stark captain america the
avengers they're big names right when
people think about the avengers they
think about like the earth's mightiest
heroes right like the people who save us
from all kinds of threats but when they
think of luke cage they think of one of
us and that's the difference that's the
huge difference the captain america iron
man thor those guys they sit up there in
the tower and people don't say that from
a place of of like vindictiveness right
they don't see that from a place of
cynicism like they're up there in their
tower and they don't care about us i
mean of course they do they save the
world but there's a big difference
between looking at a superhero who saves
the world and looking at a superhero who
essentially looks out for you luke cage
has never won a mask luke cage was part
of heroes for hire he originally
launched it right like ground level
superheroes helping out people on the
ground level always looking out for his
own in his neighborhood that word
spreads and so people look at luke cage
like he's one of us right he looks out
for us as the little guy he knows our
names he shops at our stores he buys
food from our restaurants that's how
people see him and so that's why when
luke cage comes along and it's like do
me a solid guys right like delete the
video no one needs to know we're here
they're like yeah man of course like
we'll definitely help you out luke cage
right it's a matter of perception now
from there you switch over to spider-man
here's one thing that i do want to
specify this whole thing that's going on
right now this is actually been riley
and the reason why this whole thing is
going on to kind of sidetrack from
devil's reign for a second this deals
with something called the beyond
corporation now contrary to what you may
believe while the beyond corporation was
established back in 2006 in the next
wave comics as far as we're aware they
don't have any direct ties to the
beyonders which is a little strange
because the beyond corporation basically
consists of people who exist beyond the
multiverse right like they literally go
into universes and just cause problems
for people it's really all they do and
they do it because it's fun the way this
had played out is that peter parker is
essentially in a coma that during the
events of
spider-man 76 i think that peter parker
had basically been exposed to like a
huge amount of radiation which had
basically taken him out of commission
now during that time the beyond
corporation had basically gotten
involved and essentially appointing ben
riley as the officially recognized
spider-man and they did this because
they essentially bought the copyrights
to spider-man operating on a private
level which i didn't even know that was
something you could do
and in fact that's what happens to the
comics ben reilly's like i didn't even
know that could be done but the beyond
corporation dead right and because peter
parker is basically a broke guy how's he
going to fight a massive corporation
with seemingly endless resources and so
with peter out of commission ben riley
has been appointed to be the new
spider-man and that's why he is here so
it's kind of a cool thing because as
this goes on you start to realize that
of course he's basically stepping in on
behalf of like robbie robertson and
those guys because what you have here is
taskmaster and whiplash now whiplash
cool whatever who cares taskmaster is
the guy taskmaster's the dude i love
tony masters right you guys anybody
who's been around this channel long
enough knows i love tony masters but i
love him almost as much as i love
captain carrot captain carrot i love
captain carrot captain carrot's a super
bunny i love him right like i love me
not inland but like i love the character
i love the character of taskmaster
because he's just he's so
underappreciated but when he shows up
things are cool and as interesting as it
was seeing the taskmaster in the marvel
cinematic universe i really wish it had
been tony masters i loved the character
of tony masters but it was still cool to
see that version of the taskmaster i
digged it either way but regardless of
course ben riley steps in now here's the
thing to understand ben reilly is not an
incapable spider-man and ben reilly
knows enough to know what taskmaster is
capable of the big difference here is
that peter parker would have handled
this differently than ben reilly did
right ben riley knows who task master is
he knows what task master is about and
the funny thing about this is the way
he's written here if you didn't know it
was ben riley you would think it was
peter parker now a lot of that's because
ben is a clone of peter right from the
old clone saga story so it makes sense
their mannerisms would be very very very
very similar but the important thing
here is that you basically have a fight
that breaks out between the two of them
now the fight's really really cool right
because immediately taskmaster starts to
get the upper hand on ben reilly which
is exactly what you would expect right
fighting taskmaster is fighting captain
america or deadpool or even peter parker
or somebody like the incredible hulk
minus the strength or captain america
with his martial arts or batroc the
leaper right like when you fight
taskmaster you're fighting a legion of
different superheroes because he masters
and he knows all of their fighting
styles it's what made him so cool it's
one of the things i love so much about
him right it is a sight to behold
especially the fights between tax master
and captain america those fights are the
stuff of legend man i don't know how
many of you guys anybody out there who's
watching this video right now if you've
read the fight between taskmaster and
captain america you know what i'm
talking about the fights are amazing
especially when like captain america is
analyzing taskmaster as they fight and
he's like calling out who it is the
taskmaster is mimicking as they fight
it's so cool i know todd hashicoats did
that recently it was amazing but here's
here's the thing right right off the bat
because ben reilly realizes that he
cannot get the upper hand on taskmaster
as he's facing off against him and
whiplash because whiplash is basically
holding people hostage that at any point
in time whiplash could kill those guys
because of the electric tentacles he has
it's got more than enough electricity to
take those guys out so that's why he's
like one i've gotta get my mind off the
idea that hostages are in danger and
then two we're fighting in a confined
space which is true spider-man fights
better when he's in an open space he can
do fine in a confined space but when
he's got some room to move when he can
use his webbing to kind of get around
right when he can get distance between
himself and taskmaster then it makes
things a lot easier and so what he
actually does is he goads whiplash
largely because whiplash is an idiot but
he basically goads them right he's like
hey man so i know you consider yourself
an a-list villain but i gotta ask man
how does it feel to be like a b or c
list villain where you're basically
following orders and guarding hostages
and of course that goad's whiplash long
enough for him to be able to get the
upper hand on whiplash and essentially
take him out and so with that being the
case the fight then turns to taskmaster
the crazy thing about this is that like
ben reilly just can't handle him because
the impact of fighting whiplash despite
his modified spider-man suit is enough
that it temporarily weakens him which
allows hass master to slap the inhibitor
collar around his neck and then
basically throw him out of the building
now of course he knows ben reilly will
survive the guy crashes into a car and
then from there he's basically taken by
taskmaster and essentially arrested
right and so from there what you end up
doing is switching over to the fantastic
four remember reed richards susan storm
they were taken by the forces of kingpin
that's the thing ben grimm and johnny
storm and then franklin and valeria had
basically been whisked away which by the
way i want to answer a question a lot of
people were asking in the last video
which is why doesn't franklin do
something about this right keep in mind
that one franklin's not on the same
level that he used to be and two it's a
macguffin kind of thing right the yes
franklin can alter reality stuff like
that he can do all kinds of crazy stuff
he's a a powerhouse in the universe but
you can't have every problem solved by
franklin right because then that just
becomes the status quo right franklin
uses his reality warping abilities and
everybody forgets the superheroes are
outlawed including wilson fisk and the
day save right like literally every
story would end with franklin richards
waving his hand so that's why you don't
really see him invoked all that often
it's also one of the reasons why marvel
keeps him relatively young because with
jonathan hickman writing adult franklin
richards the way he did especially
during the fantastic four run and the
avengers new avengers run that with that
level of power franklin could seemingly
do anything right you combine that with
the history of the marvel universe comic
that marvel wrote which is interesting
that franklin merges with galactus at
the end of all reality and is born anew
the two of them kind of being a
composite being that's more powerful
than the sum of their parts and so it's
one of those things where franklin just
doesn't get used that much because the
nature of his powers is such you would
expect him to simply just end everything
and so what's kind of funny here with
regards to susan and reed is there's not
a whole lot doing there's basically just
a fight that breaks out inside the uh
inside the prison but it seems like it's
supposed to operate as a distraction so
the two of them can actually end up
engineering their own escape presumably
helping others escape as well but we'll
kind of have to read you know read
further on to find out what's going on
with that but the cool thing here is
what you end up doing is you switch over
to uh to doctor octopus who is basically
working alongside wilson fisk and the
idea here is that dr octopus's mind and
the technology he's able to utilize
would basically set things up so that
wilson fist could dominate the purple
man and then seemingly steal his powers
and then use that for the purpose of
basically controlling new york that with
kingpin while he was elected mayor if
you guys recall the last video that we
talked about he was elected mayor
because of the fact that he had
instilled trust in people that that's
not something you can rely on right
people are incredibly finicky they will
support you in one month and then hate
you the next right because the average
american just doesn't know what they
want right like their wants just sort of
change there's no consistency when it
comes to american people and so wilson
fisk and realizing that wants to
solidify his ability to remain mayor by
basically using the powers of the purple
man and that while he won't necessarily
be able to control people he will be
able to influence them right push them
to the polls get them to vote for wilson
fisk different things like that and
basically maintain power and as long as
no one knows that he's using the
abilities of the purple man to do it no
one will be any the wiser now the funny
thing about this is that otto octavius
is no idiot you guys know that right
auto octavius is no fool and he knew
right off the bat once he realized the
plan of wilson fisk was to utilize
purple man that wilson fisk would try to
use those powers on him and so what he
did is he created neural blockers that
would actually block the powers of the
purple man from being able to influence
him so literally like like kingpin tries
to use those powers on him and he's like
no you're good man uh the the influence
of pro-man doesn't work on me right
those pheromones don't affect me i've
got neural blockers but i'll leave you
to do your thing and basically leaves
right of course you're also finding out
that elektra is there to essentially
face off against craven the hunter which
looks like it would be a really really
cool fight but once you get to the
sub-basement of avengers mansion with
tony stark in them that remember tony
stark's goal here right the plan quote
unquote for defeating wilson fisk is for
tony to actually run against him and
what happens is that once they get into
the facility like luke hage is like tony
we gotta talk about your plan dude like
you running against wilson fisk that's
not gonna work that's not gonna happen
because it's basically rich guy versus
rich guy right like it's too much of a
toss-up could you win possibly right
you're very very famous people know you
right but at the end of the day we need
someone that people are more likely to
identify with right people want one of
their own now in all honesty there is a
reason why we don't just walk down the
street and ask any swinging dick if they
want to run for president of the united
states right like we've had an answer to
that question we obviously don't want to
have to go through that again but luke
cage kind of approaches this from the
perspective of like i think i should be
the one to run so while the mayor is not
on the same level as the president the
fact remains putting an average joe in
such a position of power could
potentially be disastrous that despite
luke cage's best intentions he doesn't
know what it means to run an entire city
and everything that goes on there i mean
here in the real world you just gotta
deal with new york as it exists now
right in the comics you gotta deal with
new york as it exists now plus
superheroes and super villains
you gotta deal with all that stuff and
so at the end of the day he was like
look like this is about beating wilson
fisk it's not about your ego it's not
about you wanting to be mayor or
anything like that like it's about the
fact that wilson needs to go down and
honestly you are not in the best
position to do this right like you are
tony stark the superhero community is
still a little distrustful of you
because a lot of the things that have
happened your history's sketchy there
are things about your own personal life
that the general public knows they would
not necessarily be a be a fan of right
you're not the best person for this and
so what ends up happening is that luke
says like are you on board with this and
the response of iron man is yeah sure
but obviously there's some disdain there
right obviously iron man is not a big
fan of what's going on now how far that
goes we don't entirely know right we're
not really sure exactly how that's going
to happen what we do know is switching
over to dr octopus what you end up
getting here is him basically having
this kind of of internal monologue where
he says wilson fisk is a small man
thinking small let him hold his small
amount of power as always otto octavius
understands true power true power is the
laboratory of the mad scientist reed
richards with his wild inventions like
an interdimensional gate so let fists
control a city my plans as ever are
superior and what we end up finding out
is that dr octopus has opened this
dimensional gate and then seemingly
brought in wolverine ghost rider and the
incredible hulk from an alternate
universe what he plans on doing with
these guys i have no clue but i am
ridiculously excited to find out like i
am so excited to find out also i feel
like we should cover some of the tie-ins
for this let me know if you guys want me
to cover some of the tie-ins because
like some of the tie-ins look really
good i gotta say devil's reign is a cool
story i love this man like i just i'm
i'm loving this story so far i hope you
guys are loving it too but i hope you
guys are loving this as much as i am
it's a great story but we're going to
bring this to an end thank you guys for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace